[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and just like that Megan Marco proves
that even a duchess can have a really
awkward moment I never thought my life
would be that awesome it all went down
at Tuesday's opening ceremony for the
10th annual one young world summit in
London make it attended for her third
time as councillor for the extraordinary
young leaders and her first time is a
member of the royal family and VP of the
Queen's Commonwealth Trust
[Music]
her wave was flawless so was her long
walk to the stage but when the 38 year
old new mom approached the charity's
co-founder Kate Robertson with open arms
well we'll just let you watch it again
[Applause]
[Music]
instead of going in for the hug
Robertson remembered her manners and
attempted a curtsy which just resulted
in a very hilarious embrace luckily both
women laughed it off and eventually
shared a proper hug and it seems the
Duchess has a sense of humor her Sussex
Royal Instagram account shared a video
clip from the event showing the
relatable moment from a different angle
the appearance marks Megan's first since
her new documentary Harry and Megan in
African journey premiered on Sunday and
if you thought her awkward hug was
humanizing just wait till you see her
incredibly vulnerable moment when asked
about the relentless media scrutiny
she's been facing over the last year
it's a lot so you add this on top of
just trying to be a new mom or trying to
be a newly Wed it's yeah well I guess
and also thank you for asking because
not many people have asked if I'm okay
but it's it's a very real thing
to be going through behind the scenes
and the answer is would it be fair to
say not really okay it's really been a
struggle yes
we're sending you all the hugs Megan
[Music]